We're going to get started with doctor Sharon Homan,
uh,
who is the president of Sinai Urban Health Institute,
who's going to share with us about why we needed data from the beginning.
Great.
And I want to introduce our colleague Pam Brush,
an epidemiologist at Sinai Urban Health Institute who leads our,
what's called our here strategy health equity and assessment research strategy.
So we're super thrilled to be here at Google with all of you.
And I just want to express our team's great gratitude to all of our friends and
colleagues,
your family,
Miriam,
who truly has supported us for these hundred years.
And we look forward to another hundred years.
So before we talk a little bit about our two sister institutes,
Sinai community and students,
Sinai Urban Health Institute.
I want to tell you a little bit about what we want to do today,
but before I do that,
just really want to ground in our mission.
Everything that we do in our two institutes revolves around our mission and our
mission and vision is so straight forward.
It said our patients and communities thrive and health.
And just as Marion mentioned,
the neighborhoods that we've served for a hundred years are the stories of
immigrant neighborhoods in the south at Holy Cross hospital,
Lithuanian Catholic families in the Mount Sinai community,
Lithuanian and Eastern European Jews.
And over these hundred years,
lots of different groups have moved in.
One thing that they shared in common,
our experiences of being socially religious,
politically marginalized,
that histories of racial segregation,
red lining,
economic hardship and and just appreciating that is so important to understand
what we want to share today,
which is our,
our research strategy,
the paradigm of translating data into action that improves health.
Because if we're going to carry out that mission and we're a safety net hospital
system with very little financial margin,
it takes a lot just to be treating those trauma victims that we just heard about
and taking care of people who are under insured.
But for us to really be about promoting the health of the community,
we want to do it in ways that are measurable,
that are meaningful and that are sustainable.
And we believe the only way to do that is to do it with the communities,
but doing it with communities that for generations have experienced the kind of
feelings of being something less than a full participants in society.
It means that the first thing in our research paradigm is building a certain
kind of trust.
So many of you at Google think about bringing products to market and maybe
you've used knowledge management strategies where you think about at each level
engaging your end users and your consumers and trying to build a useful product
that could go to market and you think about it the lowest level you have the
data and creating data lakes and then you take that through analytic techniques
and began to develop useful information that Kelp and farm you about bringing a
product to market and then that useful information is converted to actionable
knowledge when you tie it in with a knowledge of the food and of the field and
trends.
Similarly,
it's Sui,
we have a knowledge management strategy,
but really we call it a knowledge ecology because at every step it's a very
relational process from the type of data that we collect,
how we collect that data,
how we use in prayer ties our learnings to what action steps that we take to
work with our communities to improve health.
So what we're going to be talking about today is translating data into action
that improves health,
that's built in this paradigm,
this Knology collegey paradigm.
But before we get started on that,
a little bit more about her institutes and Debra,
all yours.
Well thank you.
So,
um,
I want to start by saying on this day
at approximately 12 new on a Tuesday,
I was born at Mount Sinai hospital
and I want to say that I'm a proud babies boomer.
So I'm not telling you what year it is,
but I'm a grunt.
I'm a baby boomer.
But,
um,
and I also want to say,
you know that Mount Sinai was there to bring me into this world when I would
have been considered a high risk birth because I was a breech birth.
And there were in that time,
I probably wouldn't be sitting here,
but had it not been the fact that they had physicians that were prepared for any
kind of condition.
I am here today.
I also want to say that,
um,
my parents migrated north from Louisiana and many of my neighbors who,
uh,
and we lived in north Lawndale and,
um,
my parents left Louisiana as those who live next to me for a better life.
And I would say as w Miriam that folks who,
who helped create,
uh,
Mount Sinai hospital and the Jewish community came to Chicago and to North
Lawndale for a better life,
no different.
Um,
I,
my memories of North Lawndale was where we could go outside and play.
Uh,
we talk about the Douglas Park where you could go and sleep at night and,
and um,
in the schools I remembered the red light,
green light game,
uh,
where we,
we came out.
It was no question about our education,
all of those kinds of things.
So I have great memories of growing up in North Lawndale.
Um,
fast forward.
We're here today.
Um,
and let me just say this,
when coming up in north Lawndale and being raised by parents who wanted a better
life,
there were certain things that were non negotiable from my parents.
Education was non negotiable.
We had to get our education during summer.
We had to do two things.
We had two options.
Either go to school or work.
Bottom line,
we didn't play.
We had to get our education.
So I decided I was going to get my education.
There was no,
there was,
it was not acceptable to come to,
uh,
to bring a report card home with a average,
you know,
unless he,
my dad was saying,
did you do your best?
And if my best was a c,
that was good.
But if I could,
if I could look inside of myself and I couldn't say that,
that wasn't my best,
then we had to have a conversation.
And that was the same for many of my neighbors in my community.
Mount Sinai hospital represented,
uh,
a safety net years ago for our community.
It was a place where we knew we could get well if we needed to be well when I
left,
um,
when I left the,
the,
the west side and came back,
I remember driving back and forth,
driving back and forth.
And,
and this is after the,
the,
um,
the riots and things that changed in the community and in the eighties and
nineties,
the biggest issue in our community was the fact that our babies were dying.
That infant mortality was a big issue in our community.
And I don't know about you,
but one of the things that is totally unacceptable is to see a he 11 or 12 or 13
year old,
uh,
give birth to a child.
Because while we can,
from a a clinical point of view,
we're going to make sure that that baby is as healthy as possible.
But the big question that is why I love Mt.
Sinai is,
we always said,
what's going to happen to that baby when he,
when he or she goes home,
it is not acceptable just to give,
to give birth to the child.
Um,
and say,
okay mom,
okay dad,
have a good life.
No,
we got to find out what's that life's going to look like.
We've got to figure out what that picture is going to.
How are we going to paint that picture?
And being a part of a part of Mount Sinai and the kind of board that we have,
um,
they allowed me to say,
and I've been at Mount Sinai for 32 years.
Okay.
That's a long time.
And they allowed me to say,
how are we,
in addition to being able to be the grade to,
to provide great medical care?
How can we assure that beyond the medical care,
how can we create an um,
a way in which we have a strong bridge between the community and the medical
campus?
So 25 years ago,
Sinai community institute was created and,
and for 25 years,
this past June,
we've been doing that faithfully,
is creating programs and resources for the community to make sure that every
baby that's born has a safety net,
that every senior that come this in our community that is protected every child,
um,
that's hungry,
that we know of is no longer hungry.
All the resources that need to be that be that,
that we know we can provide,
that we're providing it,
that partnerships that we create there,
we're creating it.
That's our job,
that's our responsibility.
And that's the beauty of being associated with an institution like Mt.
Sinai hospital,
like Sinai health system.
And so that's my story and I'm going to keep telling it.
So needs continued to grow and I think the economic conditions worsened in our
communities.
It became clear that not just in addition to needing these kind of supportive
services,
but that we had to drive structural change,
systemic change and that to do that we really had to document to be able to
share the story of health disparities.
And I think that's when my predecessor,
Dr Steve Whitman,
came about.
Maybe you could share a little bit about what Steve's vision is.
Well,
Steve came at the right time because wild,
uh,
Sinai health system in Mt.
Sinai hospital had been providing the types of services over throughout the
years to really change the lives and,
and to help heal our community in a variety of ways.
One of the things that we weren't doing and we needed to do is to be able to
measure our outcomes,
to really be able to say how we're doing it,
to tell our story in a different way.
And so by having Steve who's very,
very passionate about what we're calling health disparity issues,
to really bring it to the forefront,
he,
he really put a different angle on
it.
Things that we really did think about.
And so he really helped us understand how place and race really absolutely
matter in the equation.
And I think it's,
it's his legacy that helped us,
uh,
be the institute we are today.
And,
uh,
when we look at our team today,
we have this incredibly diverse group of scientists,
trained from some of the best institutions,
Notre Dame,
Duke,
University of Iowa,
University of Minnesota.
So we had this rock solid group of research scientists and health educators,
program developers,
effective communication people and what we're not,
we're not a back shop operation.
We're definitely in the forefront in the community working as leaders to develop
and implement and evaluate,
come up with new innovative solutions,
high tech,
high touch,
high community solutions that we hope can bring about greater equity and improve
health.
But to understand what we're doing,
we really have to understand this idea of health equity.
So,
um,
one of the things that we like to tell is if you just go from where we are here
in the West loop and you think about just going five miles west,
that we experience a decrease in life expectancy of 16 years and that's age
adjusted rates,
adjusted life expectancy.
So we say that we have this huge gap.
What are those underlying issues?
Uh,
economic depression,
race,
gender,
immigration status,
all of these characteristics.
Um,
cause our communities to experience less health and those health disparities do
more than just add burden of,
of difficult situations in homes.
Uh,
kids with unmanaged asthma,
uncontrolled diabetes.
But it really erodes the trust in our community that,
that the rest of the city of Chicago cares about them.
And to churn this around,
we really believe that we have to do it.
Think systematically.
And part of that systematic change is getting at these underlying health
inequities and making those right.
And Pam's going to share a little bit about the language that we use.
Your mouth equity and disparity,
right?
So at its heart,
suis mission is to achieve health equity across communities.
So what we mean by health equity is that all people,
all communities have access and opportunity to reach their full potential of
health.
And in,
in terminology wise,
we call health inequities are these created barriers?
So structural,
systematic barriers,
things like community disinvestment,
um,
food insecurity,
discrimination that lead to one group persistently having worse health outcomes
than another group.
And then we measure those in what we call health disparities.
So for an example of a disparity we know of,
um,
African American women who are diagnosed with breast cancer are more likely to
die then non Hispanic white woman.
And that is not a genetic predisposition.
That is because of these inequities that exist.
And Sue he's mission is really to use data in innovative solutions to try to
bridge that gap and solve some of these inequities.
Yeah.
Is that we see,
I love the work of my predecessor,
Dr Steve Whitman did because he really helped us understand this idea of health
disparities.
But to take action,
we need to think of tangible health inequities,
those things that get in the way that we can remove those barriers.
We can improve the transit system at Mount Sinai.
So not only patients can get on the bus and make it to Sinai,
they can actually get home.
Again,
we can find ways to get grocery stores built in our community or other sorts of,
uh,
Amazon,
Google solutions to the issues of food security.
But basically when we talk about removing these health equity barriers,
we need to think about three concepts.
And these are the concepts of space,
power and authority.
Of course space.
We need conditions where people can live,
work and learn.
We need green space.
We need grocery stores,
good transportation,
effective policing,
safe streets.
So that space that makes a lot of sense.
Power makes a lot of sense.
We need partners,
business partners,
commercial partners,
civic partners,
ways that we can move the needle on improving the health conditions and
eliminating some of these health barriers,
these inequities.
But most important,
we need authority.
And that's not authority over.
It's the opportunity for individuals and communities to be the author of their
own life and story.
And this is really yet what's root of our research model.
This idea that we create this platform of trust.
And when we have trusting relationships,
we can effectively engage our community members and community organizations and
partners and beginning to look at the data,
make sense of it,
prayer ties,
what we're going to work on,
find solutions that can be really adapt it to the particular community and their
needs.
So that leads into,
uh,
one example of how we were really doing this on the ground today.
And this is our Sinai survey 2.0 and so this is actually a follow up survey to
survey we did in 2002.
Uh,
and like that survey,
it really focuses on the social factors that influence people's health,
where they live,
work and play.
So this survey was conducted in nine community areas across Chicago.
Uh,
and many of these areas are served by Sinai health system,
but we actually added some other areas to get up our sample size to do some
racial and ethnic differences analyses,
particularly in Mexican and Puerto Rican populations.
Now key to engaging the community in this process was our community advisory
committee.
So they saw us through every step of the survey.
They literally oversaw the design of the survey,
uh,
the administration of it and its dissemination.
It was comprised of at least two individuals from each of the surveyed
communities and just an example of of what they did.
So we came to them with a list of 700 questions related to health and they
brought us down to 500 questions,
really tweaking them to be culturally appropriate,
uh,
and also to be the most relevant questions for their communities.
In addition,
we had them add questions so we weren't going to ask about intimate partner
violence and they insisted we ask about intimate partner violence.
They wanted us to ask about school closings in the area and they also wanted us
to ask extensively about discrimination in,
in their communities.
Now as an epidemiologist,
in addition to the community play piece,
we also tried to make sure it was a very rigorous survey.
So we did partner with the University of Illinois Survey Research Laboratory to
build a multistage sampling approach so that we could statistically estimate,
uh,
health outcomes and factors by community area.
And lastly,
we did the survey face to face in people's homes,
in Spanish and in English.
And that was done very pointedly.
It's because we know that typical survey form,
so online telephone paper tend to miss some of the most marginalized
communities,
low income people and communities of color.
And it was an incredibly important that the survey reached those groups that are
oftentimes missed in other survey forms
as well as building the trust in the community.
Right?
Yes.
Right.
Great.
So Pam is going to share a few of the key results and we're going to focus on
three topics.
Uh,
posttraumatic stress disorder,
food insecurity in neighborhood safety.
And just want to point out is Pam described some methods,
both of the analysis and the findings,
but also how we're going to disseminate those research products.
Everything that we try to do,
the prioritization of what we are sharing with you,
even today,
air ways in which we're trying to build the trust and motivation of our
communities and get their buy in.
So the one to use these findings and results to help push forward for a change
in,
um,
motivation to change.
And I,
I know Deborah,
just the past couple of weeks,
your group in North Lawndale has been using these surveys to do just that and
some of our tools.
Yes,
yes.
Um,
one to the,
um,
it's an organization called the north Lawndale triple c,
which is a community collaborative collaborative that has been actually using is
a bottom up approach.
It's a organization that was formed by the community where they wanted to come
up with a plan for what North Lawndale looks like 50 years from now because none
had been done.
And so they asked me if I would serve as the chair of the health and wellness
committee committee.
So what I felt was important is,
well,
let's find out what the,
the,
the condition of community is around health status.
So what we did is we took the data that came out of this study and we shared it
with the committee and the committee is made up of community stakeholders.
And from that we were able to come up with a plan that is reflective of the data
that was shared from,
um,
from the,
the study.
So it was really a wonderful plan that actually will be unveiled by the,
by the committee in November.
And we're going to see that some of those findings are quite startling.
Yeah.
Right.
So one of the things that we found and was quite striking to us was the immense
mental health burden in the communities and particularly in relation to PTSD.
And so we asked respondents if a health care provider or doctor had ever told
them that they have PTSD.
And here you can see the results of of diagnosed PTSD.
So they were actually quite high and we see in three communities we're
approaching about one in 10 adults having been diagnosed with PTSD.
And mind you there were,
it was basically an entirely civilian population that we were surveying.
The important thing we know also is that these communities have a lot of
barriers to healthcare,
particularly mental health care services.
So we asked a series of questions to about current PTSD symptoms in the past
month and here we see the results of that assessment.
And so we find that the burden was quite higher if we asked about it in terms of
current PTSD symptoms rather than requiring someone to go to a doctor to report
that they've been diagnosed with PTSD.
And here you see men on the left and women on the right.
And in two of our communities we had about one out of four adults reporting
current PTSD symptoms and just in the past month.
So this is quite surprising to us,
but I know an and some dissemination activities,
it wasn't actually surprising to our communities.
And Deborah,
I know it wasn't necessarily surprising to you,
so it might be good to share some of your thoughts on these phones.
It's still a stigma,
particularly in the minority communities around seeking out care around the
mental health issues.
And so,
um,
that's something that our committee,
we are addressing.
As a matter of fact,
we just did,
um,
at a conference in two of our elementary schools,
two weeks ago,
uh,
focused on,
with our own trauma informed care with our youth.
And it was phenomenal because we figured we need to start early to deal with the
how trauma is affecting our children and the and working with our youth as early
as possible.
We are walking around with a lot of pain and we need to figure out how do we
address that pain.
So in addition to the outcomes,
we also asked a bunch of questions related to factors that might influence
health,
health and particularly social factors.
So we ask things about police encounters,
discrimination,
religion,
social support,
neighborhood safety,
and the list goes on.
But one of the things I want to cover that was particularly poignant in these
communities is food insecurity.
And so for those of you unfamiliar with Food Insecurity,
it's a measure of access to not only affordable food but healthy,
nutritious food.
And we used the U S DA's validated scales so that we could compare it to other
surveys across the country.
And here you see some of the questions and what they really get at.
And in our communities,
we saw that all but one were well above the u s rate for household food
insecurity in the past year.
In fact,
in three of our communities we were approaching one and two households being
food insecure.
In addition,
looking at this by race and ethnicity,
we found that our non Hispanic black households were three times as likely and
are Puerto Rican and Mexican households about two times as likely to be food
insecure as white households.
So this is incredibly important as a health care provider to see what our
patients were facing it at home.
You know,
a lot of our providers are trying to get people to stay on to complex medical
schedules,
get them onto prescriptions for their different health needs.
But it's important to remember that if you can't get food on the table,
it's oftentimes hard to meet those clinical guidelines.
Yeah,
you,
you look at,
in our community,
north Lawndale,
largely African American community where Mount Sinai sits,
and as we see from the statistics,
about half of the African American families in those communities are food
insecure.
And you remember back to what that meant,
that Pam shared with us from the,
from the FDA instrument,
this means they go days without any food.
And then I just wanted to run that by at Mount Sinai are the folks that are in
nutrition and dietetics.
And I asked,
well,
what's the situation particularly for our patients that have complex medical
conditions are have come in for an emergency episode related to their diabetes.
So what is it like?
And she said,
well,
and they said that almost three fourths of our patients leave and they leave
with a nutritional issue.
They're undernourished or malnourished.
They'd been in the hospital,
they've lost weight,
and they go back and they don't have a ready access to food.
There are no solutions in the community,
there aren't grocery stores.
This is a huge issue.
And I know Debra,
it's something you're looking as part of the quality of life plan and in North
Lawndale,
right?
So this data was incredibly important to guide our practice,
to guide our interventions.
But one of the key pieces of the survey was that we involve the community along
the way.
And one of the key ways we did this was in our dissemination.
So one of our primary dissemination methods were to coast community with topics
that were selected by our community advisory committee and get residents
feedback on the context around these numbers.
So these were round tabor table discussions in English and in Spanish.
We kind of did a data training at the beginning where we communicated to
individuals how to,
how to understand the data,
and then we asked does this resonate?
What's the context?
And these were incredibly important to us understanding the different narratives
across our communities.
So I'll give one example here.
Uh,
so this is the story of North Lawndale and West Englewood.
So these are two communities on the west and south sides of Chicago,
about eight miles apart.
Uh,
and they look pretty similar.
Demographically they're about the same size and they're both predominantly non
Hispanic black populations.
They also have quite low median incomes.
Compare it to the city as a whole.
And their clinical access is pretty much the same.
So beyond these statistics,
um,
you know,
they were getting access to screenings at appropriate times,
et cetera.
So your thought might be that all of their other outcomes might be pretty
similar or,
or you know like everything probably looks about the same.
But we also asked about these social factors and one of the things we asked
about with safety,
and we found that in north Lawndale about 16% of adults felt unsafe walking
alone in their house,
in their neighborhood during the day.
But that in west Englewood it was one in three.
So as the data people we are,
we dug into it and we were thinking that it probably was related to crime,
but we actually found that north Lawndale had higher rates of violent crime than
West Englewood.
So we weren't quite sure what was going on with the numbers and we didn't have
additional numbers to help answer these questions.
And so we discussed this at our forums and overwhelmingly this is what we heard
at our west Englewood forum.
So things like,
it feels like Inglewood is a target to just report the bad stuff and the media
has constant images of violence,
but people don't see that.
If we're constantly slammed with this image will be looking over our shoulders
rather than reaching out to each other.
And so working in health promotion and capacity building in this neighborhood,
it was incredibly important to hear this message because we don't oftentimes
think about the media and its influence on the factors that influence health.
And so in our programming,
we're trying to incorporate means and levers to push back on this negative
portrayal,
not only for the outsiders,
but also for community members themselves.
So they really understand the assets that are there because only by building up
that capacity and that power and that belief in these communities,
will they be able to really take control of their own future and health.
This ties back to what we said at the beginning,
that most important principle that we do this kind of research.
So it gives an authorship the ability of the community,
be able to tell their own story and not having the media tell their story and to
empower communities,
they have real data and qualitatively and quantitatively to tell the story.
Right.
So very true.
And I'll give one more example of kind of how,
how we're doing that.
So this is a slightly different story of North Lawndale and little village,
which is also referred to a South Lawndale,
just not to confuse anyone.
And these two communities are served by Mount Sinai hospital and they're ones
directly north on Ogden avenue in one's directly south on Ogden Avenue.
So right next to each other.
They do look strikingly different demographically though.
Um,
so north Lawndale is predominantly non Hispanic,
black and little village is actually much denser population wise.
And then also predominantly people of Mexican descent.
It has a very large immigrant community.
Now both of these communities do not fare well in terms of income and hence both
do not fare well in terms of food insecurity.
So they're quite high levels.
And so Mount Sinai doing a lot of work in the community may have the thought of,
we could just do the same approach in both of these communities.
And some of the things we heard at the forums would suggest that the pathways to
food insecurity where the same before between these two communities.
So minimum wage issues,
lack of beneficial employment,
um,
really expensive healthy food costs.
But as we continued to discuss with community members,
we really found the narratives and the pathways were quite different.
And so in North Lawndale people talked about how it was a physical food desert.
There were grocery stores,
people had to go on two or three buses or get additional gas money to get to
food.
And we actually,
after hearing this,
pulled up some numbers to,
to go with these statements in it.
And it's true.
And then in little village we found a little different story going on.
So as I mentioned,
it was,
it's a large immigrant community and what we heard overwhelmingly there was that
there's resources here,
but a lot of people are fearful of accessing them,
particularly in the current political environment.
And so people were saying regardless of citizenship status,
if a pantry was asking for an ID,
they would not go there for fear of where their name would be listed going
forward.
In addition,
there was a lot of confusion about accessibility of food stamps.
And this really helped us because we actually have some numbers from the survey
on food stamps and on,
um,
emergency food access.
And it really helped us see the why these inconsistencies and our numbers were
happening.
And so this happened time and again that we heard different,
we saw similar data but we heard different pathways at our community forums.
Okay.
So we've showed the story of some of our results and we want to get those
results into the hands of different stakeholders,
policy makers,
community members,
community organizations like Deborah's.
And so we developed this really cool dissemination strategy that Pam's going to
walk us through.
Um,
yes.
So to hit all of our different stakeholders,
uh,
we first came out with a very large report on 16,
16 different health topics.
It was perfect for a media release and getting it out early to all the press,
like very formal and professional.
You all would,
as data minded people might find this the most interesting of the things that we
released.
Um,
and then the second thing we did with go back to the community.
So these were info graphics that had one piece of data on them.
Uh,
and what they really tried to do was bring attention to a particular issue in
the communities themselves.
And our community advisory committee helped us decide which,
what topics will be discussed.
And then lastly,
really for policymakers,
Alderman funders,
people interested in the areas.
We released these series of profiles.
So all of this is available on our website along with videos.
We didn't want to Belabor all 500 questions we asked here today.
Um,
but you can find information on a lot of them on our website.
Great.
So this gets us to moving from usable information to actionable knowledge.
So having a trusted a set of data and tools that can be leveraged to a support
community efforts.
What are we going to do with it?
We heard some things,
Debbie already shared with us,
things that we're doing with Northland dope collaborative,
but then we found a really cool thing that people want to do with it.
Another initiative of Sinai health side of Sinai health system that Karen
Teitelbaum initiated is the Chicago gun violence research collaborator.
And Deborah and I had been very active in this collaborative and we did a lot of
community listening sessions.
So what,
how does the community want us to help them really address this problem of
violence?
And here's one of the surprising things we heard.
It was help our youth stay,
help our youth get engaged and we want our youth to know that they can have
research and data at their fingertips,
teach him to be research activist.
And so one of the things you were going to be doing is bringing in a cohort of
youth this summer and the learn things about advocacy and media and use of data
and Info graphics and we'll begin to uh,
build the next generation of Google researchers.
So for you go glare,
sewer,
thinking about how could you use some of the things that we've shared,
we say involve the communities,
particularly the youth.
If you're not doing that already.
And think about how you can enhance your own research and bringing new products
to market by really this direct community involvement,
particularly being attentive to some of the more disenfranchised communities.
And then of course,
sign up for information and learn more about us.
And,
uh,
Debra.
Yeah.
And I guess the last nugget I would recommend,
um,
as you go into the community,
always take a step back and say,
whose Lens Am I?
Am I really seeing this information through?
Because that's real important just to reflective of that.
Um,
because we each bring our own experience to the table.
And so we want to understand what experience we're bringing to the table and how
we're interpreting that information because,
um,
the community is,
you know,
very smart people and they've,
uh,
we don't need to empower them because they are very much empowered these days.
So when we want to do is work hand in hand with the community and just make sure
that we understand the lens by which we're seeing them and they're seeing us so
great.
So he got a perfect summary.
Forest,
Pam,
you know,
to us,
we're hoping to leave you today with the idea that place does matter,
that the methods we use to understand those places matter and that ultimately in
the end,
our communities matter no matter where they're from,
who lives there.
Um,
that we all have the right to justice and to health.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
as Google we have a lot of power to disseminate information.
Um,
what are some things that tech companies like us can do to help spread the word
share with Nick's face?
Why don't you go ahead and go?
I know it's in a week
dreams.
So we'd done this sort of in three phases,
the traditional kind of research and then thinking about creative ways we could
disseminate but about as creative as we got were things like these infographics.
And then we've also created a little,
a little podcast and Info live infographics,
but we don't know how to get it to the next level.
How to get it out and just be common parlance and people using it in the social
media and thinking about these issues and discussing them.
So how could you help us with that?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think the first thing is that we'll,
we'll post this talk on youtube and I encourage you all to share it and post it
to your circles.
Um,
um,
yeah,
but I think that's something that we as Google or should think about is that
there's,
you know,
the people don't have resources,
but also institutions like sign,
I don't have resources like we have Google and how can we get their message out?
Yeah.
That's the only thing included along the lines of a drug abuse or opioids,
which is a very public thing right now.
And did you look into that and research and factor in as well?
Yeah,
so we did.
So our first survey,
we actually didn't ask about drug use and substance use,
but our community advisory committee insisted this time that we do.
Um,
they were,
everyone was very insistent about it.
So we did ask about them and about substance use and drug use.
We have not released though that data just yet.
We're in the process of putting it together because while we want to be
responsible about it,
we need to make sure we build a context around it so that we're not reinforcing
a lot of stereotypes in our communities.
Um,
and for the groups that we serve.
But yes,
we did ask about it,
even some of our colleagues.
So in addition,
the other dissemination form is we're writing lots of papers in peer reviewed
journals that I'm sure everyone in the world wants to read.
Um,
but we are doing some research using some of that data.
Yeah,
I can leave.
We hope to get into the world of informing policy makers and have had some
initial conversations with Kennedy Forum and others to think about ways that,
that are so critical,
like understanding the opioid epidemic,
what it means to our communities and begin to use our data to inform policy
solutions.
I'm curious just to hear more about what the response has been from policy
makers and how,
how they're using the data.
Are they denying it or are they excited about it?
Um,
and,
and then my second question is there is already so many nonprofits and other
organizations on the ground that are doing a lot of work and many of them
measured their success in their own way.
And so I'm curious how organizations that are already on the ground take
information like this and do they embrace it or have you noticed that there are
maybe a bit apprehensive to it?
So the policymaker piece,
I do an in Sharon or Deborah might be able to speak better.
I has been very well received generally.
I mean we have a couple of policymakers that we work with all the,
all the time we have been trying to get more into the policy work and advocacy
space.
Uh,
and that's a little bit slower.
It's not in our usual.
We also are working with a couple of local organizations on that,
so more to come on how that continues to move forward.
Um,
and then the second piece is actually one of the things that Sinai does
incredibly well.
Sci does well,
Sui does well is we have really great partnerships with the community based
organizations in the communities that we serve.
And so they really enjoyed having this data.
It's incredibly important for them to pursue funding to really highlight the
needs in their areas.
Um,
and oftentimes the numbers they're collecting are specific to their programs.
So these provide much broader population level estimates that they really don't
have the resources to get on their own in order to either say how things
might've changed over time,
but also to pursue additional funding and say,
you know,
we need more here to make more change.
Hey everyone,
I want to say thank you so much for the incredible work for someone who grew up
in a little village.
It was interesting to see the numbers.
I was really astonished at the similarities between North and south Lawndale.
But then it's really interesting that taking the qualitative approach you took
to inform the data driven results,
right.
Help us get a better sense of understanding.
Something that we constantly think about is,
you know,
data scientists or analysts is that the numbers don't lie,
but we do miss part of the story if we don't take that other approach.
So I really appreciate that look because you know,
there's growing up a little village,
there's just stuff to buy it at every corner from every little place but and and
across Hogben and it's a whole different story.
Um,
but you have the same levels of insecurity,
which was really,
really astonishing.
I just wanted to actually a couple of resources.
Uh,
the state,
uh,
Stacy,
Linda over at University of Chicago did a similar project on resources in the
neighborhood on women's health issues and was able to get a group of teens to,
uh,
run a program called [inaudible] Corp and they actually did a great job.
We're recruiting from them for that cohort next summer.
They're going to be the second generation of interesting thing that happened
there is Dave formed a better map of Woodlawn then we had at Google.
Right.
Um,
by a large percentage.
Right.
And that's where we fail and we kind of wake up luchadors to say we're missing
some of these communities where,
you know,
we might not spend enough time at are not everybody has access to phones and et
Cetera.
So it helps us inform our tactics,
what we might be missing,
missing things as well.
Uh,
and then the other one is for the pelvic Googlers.
Here is any amount of time that we want to volunteer or spend.
Don't forget to log your Google give ours because whether you spend an hour
helping flush out a report or share data and social,
uh,
social media or actually summer.
Yes.
And we'd love to host them in the summer as well.
Uh,
we've,
we've done that with different projects.
So,
uh,
thank you.
Definitely go online to see that and just no report,
especially growing up in little village,
there is a lot more information available.
I just wanted to ask you to,
I haven't gone through the whole process and being able to see what comes out at
the end.
If you could go back to the beginning and cheat,
you know,
what would you,
what's one thing you think you could do differently to get a more fruitful
outcome there?
Ultimately we did run into some recruitment issues and so I am not an expert in
survey design or recruitment really,
but I do know several of my colleagues,
um,
just little tweaks we could have made a little bit earlier on in terms of
getting our numbers up even higher than they were,
um,
I think would have been a,
a key elegant pieces.
I think we use traditional sample survey methods when we worked with you.
I see.
And that the unit,
the,
the household was the,
the sampling unit and I don't,
and this,
and it made it really difficult in some of the gated communities is it
particularly,
uh,
men or control communities?
But I don't think that the household is the best sampling unit.
And I think we'd want to think differently about that.
It's the whole of the balancing of all that,
you know,
the positive and negatives of each of each of the approaches.
I just some combination of those issues.
So I think we were really proud and happy with our community engagement,
but it was,
it's more of those technical issues that,
you know,
everyone who does a survey has,
so,
and I might be off base,
but what I was hearing,
particularly with the gun violence collaborative piece of it,
when he did the listening tours,
more and more communities want to B to B.
They want to be a part of the research.
So it's not where they want outsiders coming in it.
There's the whole trust factor.
And so if we could be do what we're planning to do,
which is to train more individuals from the community to be able to do their own
research,
then I think it,
I think that'll just change the,
the,
the narrative on that because I think that's where some of the,
cause I know there was a point in north Lawndale where the numbers weren't going
where it needed to be here with 10 callbacks.
We were struggling,
struggling.
And I think part of it was,
is that folks,
like I am tired of folks coming in here asking me information and,
and not giving anything back.
No more.
And so we have,
you know,
that was what I was hearing and I'm not a researcher.
And so I,
the good thing is that under Sharon's leadership,
folks listening and honoring what the community's saying.
Okay,
well thank you so much to our friends from Sinai Health Institute and Sinai
health system,
my birthday now you'll pay
everyone for coming.
Thank you.